okay so terbium just like you r opium is
often used in television screens and
various types of displays and where it
comes in is it gives green and yellow
colors which in contrast to the red and
blue which you opium gives you gives you
the full selection that you need to give
color images terbium is also used in
certain magnetic devices and when you
include it in certain alloys it forms
magnetic devices which increase or
decrease in size depending on the
strength or the type of magnetic field
which they're placed into which has
various technological applications also
because of its fluorescence nature it's
often used as a marker in biochemistry
so if you want to stain cells and
determine whether certain types are
present then you can use it for that too